nicole kidman stopped by the tonight
show and continued her trend of making
all her jimmy fallon interviews a little
awkward after revealing back in 2015
that jimmy passed up the chance to go on
a date with her a decade earlier i know
i love that this is still an ongoing
thing so during her latest appearance
jimmy attempted to do a speed round of
christmas questions but nicole wasn't
having any of it because she's a queen
take a look
ready for this
nobody told me about this part of it
what favorite holiday song
yeah um
you're so difficult
did you call me difficult
uh real tree or fake not anything better
on this list
[Laughter]
i don't know if this is this really
going to make the show no no
no it's not going to make the channel oh
i'll ask you
turkey or ham
turkey or ham i don't know what that
means uh
probably turkey i don't know these
questions are terrible any more
questions for me do you want to sit here
no all right sorry
there's nothing oh my god
they just tear they're not good okay
good thing i'll get rid of them